uh hello everyone um my name is seth
manukin i am the director of the
communications forum uh and i am only
here to introduce the speakers and then
you will no longer need to look at me
the
moderator of the conversation
is david thorburn and before
i introduce him
this is also in some ways a celebration
of david's long tenure as director of
the forum
everything that the forum is
is because of his uh through sheer force
of his will and intellect um he's been a
real driving force uh and has created
something really special here so
i know i owe him a big debt and i think
we all owe him a big debt so thank you
very much for that david
and there will be a reception
following this uh this being mit and
nothing being simple um it is not near
where we are but in
uh building 14 and 14 e 303
304 okay 14e 304. um you do not need to
go outside to get there and if you don't
know where that is you can sort of
follow the herd afterwards um but we
will have uh refreshments for everyone
um so
in addition to being the director
emeritus of the communications forum
david is
mit literature professor
and this is i believe his 40th year at
mit is that right
you don't look a day over 50. um
he started young
he has taught
courses ranging from media and
transition to comedy
and his mit lecture course the film
experience has been taught to
undergraduates for more than 35 years
and is about to be published on
opencourseware
he's the past winner of mit's mcvicker
award for exemplary contributions to
undergraduate teaching
next to him is robert pinsky
three-time u.s poet laureate the author
of 19 books which makes me tired just
thinking about
and the william fairfield warren
distinguished professor of english and
creative writing at boston university
he has won the william carlos williams
prize from the poetry society of america
the harold washington award from the
city of chicago and a lifetime
achievement award from uh the pan
american center um and you are currently
working on furthering digital education
is that right by teaching the art of
poetry through edx
alan guth who's immediately next to
robert
is mit's victor weiskopf professor of
physics
pioneer of the inflationary model of the
universe and another recipient of the
mcvicar award for exemplary
contributions to undergraduate teaching
he was an inaugural awardee of the
fundamental physics prize and a
co-recipient of the 2014 kavli prize
awarded by the norwegian academy of
science and letters
he's a member of the u.s national
academy of sciences and the american
academy of arts and sciences
and his the early universe course is
currently available through
opencourseware
and on the end of the table hazel siv is
a biology professor here at mit
principal investigator with the civ lab
and a member of the whitehead institute
for biomedical research
she has been at mit since 1991 and was
the first associate dean of the mit
school of science uh she currently has
three biology courses available through
open courseware
and was named a recipient of the
winner of the 2015 mcvicker award
for exemplary contributions to teaching
she's also a great storyteller
and i know this because she and i were
did a story collider together
and in april is going to be telling
another story on stage is that right at
the
hayden planetarium at the museum of
science
so look out for that so without any
further ado i'll turn it over to them
and thank you all for being here
i'd like to thank my distinguished
colleagues and panelists for uh
joining me on this
what i think of as sort of my farewell
forum i'd also like to remind the
audience that one of the
signature features of the forum in
during my time as director has been
interaction with the audience and our
usual format which i hope we will follow
today is about an hour of discussion
among the panelists and then an hour
with the audience and i hope though i
see a number of fellow of our fellow
mcvicar winners in the audience i hope
that the second part of our conversation
in which the audience is asked to
participate will be even livelier and
more remarkable than the first part
i asked each of our panelists to think
about uh
this question before we convene today
and i want to ask each of them now
to speak very quickly to this question i
asked each of them to think about
naming for us and describing for us a
memorable teacher from their past and
perhaps i should say parenthetically
that as i began teaching has been at the
center of my life i realize all my all
my all my life it's always been a
an activity i took as sort of central to
my experience and i
think i was always a strong and serious
teacher but i came to realize as we
approach this forum that uh
i have not too many abstract principles
to to suggest about what makes a good
teacher and i'm hoping that our
conversation will confront that problem
about how subjective many of us are
about what our what our work involves in
any case i thought i thought that one
way of getting at some of the things
that are hidden about why we value
teaching and what it is in teachers we
care about if i would ask these
distinguished teachers and and
uh practitioners scholars and writers
to describe a memorable teacher from
their past a teacher who mattered to
them very much let's start with robert
thanks david a pleasure to be here
i'm very glad to have an occasion to pay
tribute to mr angus mcwhithy
who was my teacher in the eighth grade
in long branch new jersey
in a class
it was all boys
because it was the bad class
and it was a subject that was designed
for people who were not destined to go
to college
and the subject was mechanical drawing
in the first or second meeting of the
mechanical drawing class
mr mcwhithy told us
that i believe this was i think this is
the first true intellectual discussion i
can ever remember having it certainly is
the first intellectual discussion i can
ever remember having
in a classroom
mcwhithey told us that
you begin your drawing of an object but
first elevation you do is the front of
the object
and then he said to us
what how do you determine the front of
an object
if it moves
whatever goes first
i see so what is the front of the
factory
uh well it's um
it's where things come in and out
so is the front of the toilet ball the
bottom or the top
etc
and
he got a bunch of i would describe us as
would-be thugs
he got us very interested
and arguing with one another and
supplying introductions like those uh
objections like those i've mentioned to
different theories of what is the front
of an object
and um
it isn't where things come in and out
it's if a person where a person would
come in and out
so the front of your car is the side
etc
and he may have given us the first of
those
little socratic demures or objections
and
we were having pleasure
in stretching our brain so he took this
classroom of
official dopes
and
doing very little and he was a very
stern man a very strict man
doing very little but because he knew a
good question when he asked one
he got us going
the front of an object in the mc with
the dictum is
the elevation that gives the most
information about it
alan
okay uh
when david first asked me this question
i was
in a bit of a conundrum because i really
have had a number of great teachers
from high school to college to graduate
school
so
i decided to pick one
the person i'd like to talk about is a
former mit professor no longer alive
named felix velars some of you may have
known him
he was a nuclear theory
person in the center for theoretical
physics and when i was an undergrad here
at mit
and he was our teacher for three terms
of theoretical physics
the last three terms of the physics
major
two term senior year one term junior
year
and he carried us through
one term of classical mechanics if i
remember right one term of
electromagnetic theory and then one term
of quantum theory
what characterized his teaching
was that he was not at all flamboyant
and i have a feeling if you asked
any of us sometime in the middle of that
three-term stretch
did we really think he was a great
teacher we probably would have said he
was an okay teacher but
not necessarily a great teacher
but when i began later to study for my
general exams when i was a graduate
student and went back over all those
notes
i was incredibly impressed
with how tremendously well he had
organized the material so that
everything just fit together beautifully
uh everything was just crystal clear and
i really really appreciated that i think
all of us did
he really did a fabulous job
not in making the class necessarily feel
exciting minute to minute
but in really putting across the
material in a way that made it seem so
easy we didn't even realize that we were
learning pretty sophisticated stuff
okay i i have to stand up to
tell you my thing
it's a pleasure to be here i have to
tell you i didn't know this existed
before i was invited to be here and i'm
sorry because i think it's great
no no no i think it is a wonderful
commentary on the richness of the
offerings at mit and how hidden they are
often from you know people who might be
really
engaged in them so i'm delighted that i
know this and you know
henceforth will make an effort to come
you know my teach that i want to pay
tribute to um is barry fabian who was my
professor of biology at vitz university
in johannesburg where i got my
first two degrees
that is in south africa and south africa
when i was growing up was a very in the
box kind of place educationally you it
still is to some extent but at the time
you know there was rote memorization
okay and i was good at it but that was
how we learned there was not much room
for
thinking creatively but
the day i walked into barry's class
he stood at the board he was a young
assistant professor he was going to tell
us about developmental biology which
ended up being my subject and he picked
up his chalk and he said okay i'm going
to tell you about what i'm going to tell
you about
let's just you know lay out the
groundwork and he took his chalk
and he drew a line across the board
and then
i have the disposition wrong he drew a
line across the board and then there was
a wall you know and he went on the wall
with his chalk
and he went all around the wall
and he went
across the closed door and he went up
the passageway and there was a door at
the back and he went out the door and he
walked down and he came back and he went
back
along the wall whoops where was our
board and he went back
along the board
and there we were okay
well we were incredulous we were just
stunned that a professor would you know
deface the walls and go outside the
bounds of the blackboard but it was an
unbelievably important experience
because it actually was opening up the
box you know it was opening up the box
of rote memorization that we were all in
and saying that there were ways that you
could go somewhere else that were
interesting and they were allowed he
gave us license to go somewhere else and
you know that was i would say a
transformative lecture and actually he
was a very awesome individual who still
is and now he is a dear friend of mine
but that moment of being given license
to think about whatever it was the line
was emblematic of whatever it was to
think about the line in a way that could
go beyond the bounds of where you
thought it was where you thought it was
contained i would say that you know that
was a transformation that i took with me
forever and ever that's something that's
a wonderful story i
i have an anecdote although it's a it's
a reverse it's a it's a it's an
anti-anecdote it's a it's a it's a bad
teacher anecdote
when i was a sophomore in college
i stumbled onto a course called european
backgrounds of english literature of
european backgrounds of english
literature and the first
writer on the syllabus was dostoyevsky
i'd never heard of him
i read about 50 pages of crime and
punishment and fell into a trance
i'm sure that other readers of
dostoyevsky have had this experience you
have to maybe be at the right age and
have a kind of literary energy in you
but i was overwhelmed by this book i had
never encountered a book that had the
kind of energies that seemed to me to
fall off every page and i was
i became so obsessed by by dostoevsky
that not only did i read crime and i was
taking my other courses too but not only
did i read crime and punishment on the
other books on the syllabus but i read
other dostoevsky including the brothers
karamazov within a an incredibly short
space of time too short even to remember
what was going on in the book but it was
one of those
orgies of reading that one falls into
and i wrote my term paper that only the
second term paper i'd ever been required
to write in college on dust on crime and
punishment and i poured my soul into
that paper it was a
it was a a religious experience to write
about this writer who had mattered so
who came to matter so much to me
when i got the paper back from the
professor it it it contained no marginal
uh words although there were occasional
uh vertical marks made in pencil in the
margins and question marks
two or three in the whole paper and at
the end of the paper there was this
comment a grade a b plus and a comment
not bad
that was when i resolved to be a
professor who would grade his students
papers in a respectful way
and i've tried to stick to that
for 50 years
uh i mentioned that example because i
think in fact it's often the case that
we one can be as discouraged and as
damaged by bad teaching as one can be
exalted by good teaching
one of the things that's implicit in
what in in the anecdotes in the
anecdotes we heard that i'd like us to
sort of expand on a little bit more
fully is is this
alan suggests that
the teacher the teacher he identifies as
having been valuable and important
wasn't was a person who had command of
his material
and whose mastery of the material was
communicated to the students
he even implied that this was not a
professor who was very charismatic and
exciting and passionate in the way that
we normally think interesting teachers
are
so one model that's suggested here is
just the model of intellectual mastery
at least at the level of of of
university education
where the question of the
teacher's ability to engage our us
emotionally or to fascinate us because
the teacher has some kind of charismatic
energy seems not not relevant on the
other hand hazel's
anecdote suggests a kind of charismatic
teacher who wants to shock us into an
awareness that we might not otherwise
have and implies that the classroom can
be a place of transformative surprise
whereas alan's model suggests it's a
place where of of accretive learning now
i don't mean we have to make a choice
here but i'm curious about how each of
you feel about these distinctions
and if you can say some more about them
um well i guess maybe i should speak
first i i certainly also admire
charismatic teachers i i shouldn't make
it sound like i think the only thing a
professor needs to do is to present the
facts
but in a subject like theoretical
physics the presentation of the facts is
extremely important and getting them
clear and getting the mole in a
consistent notation with the signs right
and everything
is incredibly valuable
and
i should maybe add that professor lars
was not really a dull lecturer but i
think he was not particularly
charismatic what was his particular
strength was the incredible degree to
which he was able to organize the
material
i certainly have had other teachers who
have been very charismatic and i admire
those as well and try
to the extent that i can to be a little
bit charismatic myself i think it does
help in teaching
but i at least in some subjects i think
it's also incredibly important
to
really organize the material in an
intelligent way
now one one one aspect of what you're
saying is the question of the of the
difference between a lecture class and a
and a discussion class uh the robert's
example is the example of the teacher
who interacts with individual students
in ways that awakens them in some sense
does it mean does this mean that lecture
courses that the hostility that so many
people feel toward lecture courses is
really justified
or that lecture courses are only
appropriate for really advanced level
students
do you guys have feelings about that
occurs to me that they're too
they're very similar they both refer to
a larger context in your case temporal
that your judgment of the teaching
you said that while it was happening it
was okay
then retrospectively over the years the
combination of clarity and complexity
is what made it impressive and similarly
hazel said in the context of an
extremely rigid
memorization-based
institutional structure in that context
again over time
so that in both cases there's an
historical aspect to it and uh good
teaching is in this way very different
from good performance
in fact the knockout class where he says
what a great class may not be effective
teaching at all
because there's a larger
temporal context or a larger
institutional context
and just simply making ahead is not the
point of teaching though it is done
well i have to confess that i mean one
of my anxieties all my career as a
teacher has been that i know i can fool
my students
i say i know i can make them feel that
they've had an exciting experience even
if they haven't
and i think that i think that some
gifted teachers maybe many have this
problem let's say i mean it's easy to
seem to mesmerize them if you if you
have a kind of theatrical
uh
character and i think many good teachers
do have a kind of actorly dimension to
their work but that's not the same as
being a good teacher
and and
i wonder whether you've had that same
experience
well you know i i think it's a very this
is a very complex question isn't it you
know i think there's some balance
between
the scholarship that one has to
communicate in a lecture and the
storytelling aspect which is the
engaging part of the lecture and i think
the balance shifts from the introductory
courses up to the graduate courses you
know i teach introductory biology and i
really view my role there as the erudite
storyteller who can capture you know my
large class who can
you know there's lots of aspects to this
but who can capture the large class and
tell something which is compelling
and you know if oversimplified largely
accurate and that's kind of the hook
because for a lot of these students they
are not going to get more biology as
they go through the institute so they
they need to listen and they need to be
there and you know i'm the best person
within the course with my co-professor
who can actually tell them the story of
biology and i think
i'm very aware of that at the
introductory level that there's you know
there's the information that has to be
correct but there's the engagement that
is really important
now when i teach you know my graduate
students the other semester i think the
balance really shifts to scholarship and
i think there
what is telling a story but actually
it's the scholarship it's the thread of
being able to synthesize the material
and give it to students so that they
really notch up in their way of thinking
about a topic and in their understanding
of the topic and of course you know
there's a nice sort of collegial
interaction the classes are smaller but
the dynamic is so different than the
introductory courses so i think you're
the answer to your question is a sort of
it depends you know so but you're you
would be a defender of lecture courses i
love lecture courses i think we don't
i love i love lecturing
i love you know the opportunity to have
300 parallel conversations with each of
my students i kind of view
lecture as an opportunity to have this
you know
multi-conversation i love seeing people
who are listening i love it when the
class goes really quiet and you know
that everyone really is listening
and you know yeah i think it's a we it's
an opportunity to build a community
that goes beyond the lecture material
that actually you know goes into the
whole experience of being part of the
mit community and of the particular
class so i think lecture
serves much more at the introductory
levels especially than just
communicating the information
i think as you as i said i think as time
goes on and students become more mature
the scholarship really kind of trumps
the
community aspect but i think lecture
always has the opportunity for building
community and i think building community
amongst groups is always a terrific
thing
one of the implications of our
conversation so far at least
it seems to me an implication is that
there may be a difference or perhaps
there's a difference between the demands
of a humanities classroom or a social
science classroom and a science and a
science classroom and i'm wondering
except robert and i can sort of defend
the humanities and you guys can defend
the sciences do you think there's a
difference
do you
in your practice do you believe there's
a difference
i think i have a hard time knowing how
to answer that question because i've
never taught a humanities class
i haven't even been to humanities class
in many many many years
my guess is that there are differences
but
but maybe i would say that i expect that
there's more commonalities than
differences
certainly in both cases one does need to
engage the class and i was i really like
what uh what hazel just said about
lectures i'm also a big enthusiast of
lectures
and to me a lecture really is a an
interaction between a speaker and an
audience i i don't think a lecturer is
anything like
somebody getting up in front of the
audience like a movie and just saying
things uh you're always looking at the
people
reacting to their facial expressions
even if they're not asking questions
and i think there's a very strong
element of responsiveness on the part of
the lecture
to the audience
that's very real and creates something
that
really can't happen any other way and i
would guess that's true whether what
happened but
one kind of argument that they i mean
i'm on your side of course i mean i i
love lecturing i would die if i couldn't
lecture but i i
the one complaint that they make that is
very common
about lectures is that there's something
kind of uh that the absence of
interaction is what is what people
complain about why should students sit
passively and listen to an expert
especially now in the in the in an age
when they can um
do some kind of digital search and fun
and find something online or uh in which
they can simply read the material
what justifies uh
gathering 100 or 200 students in one
space and have an expert talk to them
instead of just hand them a text hazel
gave a very good
anticipatory response to that by saying
she was 300 separate conversations
parallel conversations with her students
and that when the room falls silent you
know they're paying attention and uh
adequate lecturing good lecturing
is
interactive you you're sensing when the
students you're following facial
expressions uh you hear a lot of
coughing or less coughing
um so forth i can remember lecturing uh
shakespeare for non-majors at berkeley
and i've never taken a shakespeare
course it's just my bright ideas about
shakespeare
and
in berkeley you know dogs would wander
in and out of the classroom
there were people from telegraph avenue
who had come in to relax indoors for a
while
and it had it was like your word
communal extending into this yeah and
there are times when you could feel
at every moment you can feel a kind of
graph of tension
and and those uh and those i always
would interrupt myself would always stop
after 10 or 15 or 20 minutes and invite
remarks
well maybe the question is too difficult
or too
vague but i hope that you and the
audience will consider it too and maybe
we can come back to it when we come to
the
audience participation
yes yeah but that's the topic i want us
to sort of come back to as well but yes
of course i may be sentimental about
science um
when you said that it occurred to me
that i chose a classroom that was
teaching a technical subject if not
precisely scientific a little bit more
of an engineering subject
and i realized the last time i talked to
the extremely ambitious verb bu has a
very small
mfa program
and uh thanks to a donor
every year
eight of the bu poets
get global fellowships they go away
to for up to two months
to any non-english speaking country
the theory is it's very good for writer
particularly an american writer to
experience a different culture
these used to be competitive
fortunately or unfortunately we now have
enough money where everybody gets one
who wants one
and i had looked at the proposals
and i said to this small group of
students i'm not scolding you it may
seem i'm scrolling you i don't think
we've been exacting enough
and asking you to describe these
proposals you're not tourists you're not
there to say i had a great time in
romania or somewhere and
i
as you said that i remember that i said
to them
it's as if you're a scientist
you're doing marine biology somewhere
what are the books what's the
bibliography what are the issues what
you know
be a scientist about this i said to this
group of poets so um
and i i as i said previously that
remarkable in a way i'm sentimental
about science when there are
conversations about uh if you show a
certain film or read a certain book do
you have to give people this uh i think
the controversy is
fading a bit about uh what do they call
them trigger words and must trigger
warnings trigger warnings and i i have
said
to classes
this is like being a scientist
if this exists
and you want to study it you have to
deal with it it's part of what the
material is this is data and you you
can't ignore it so it um
i hope these aren't just figures of
speech i think it's actual respect for
knowledge which applies to my example of
good teaching he wanted us to know
something
can i make a comment about lecture you
know i'm so
interested to hear what you all think
there's so many like vicar fellows
sitting out there like i don't know i
you know we should all be around a table
rather than you know us
but i think you know i tell my advisees
you know there's two things that will
get them through a course they go to
lecture and they do the problem sets and
they'll pass
you know and i think that that is
largely true
and what is it about going to lecture
you know
and there i think we're very into
science of learning and you know
education science and so on but you know
there is a cognitive reason for that i
think if material goes in through the
eyes and it goes in through the ears and
it goes in by handwriting then there's
some neural circuits that get engaged
and there's something the student
sitting there at least has heard of it
you know it's on a piece of paper at
least has heard of it and then that can
be shored up with other
mechanisms i think you know you just
don't engage like that when you watch a
video when you read a book it's this
kind of you know three-way entry that i
i think is not substitutable and i think
unless people are actually sitting
together in a room
they're not fully engaged because you
know if you're watching it on the web
even if you're taking notes at the same
time you know you quickly just check the
news or the weather and then come back
to the lecture so i think there's
something actually that's very deep you
know that's a cognitive neuroscience
reason that there are lectures and that
lectures are really valuable and of
course they're different levels of
interesting and not interesting lectures
but i think that reason is a really
solid reason and unless humans you know
evolve i don't see that reason going
away and the value of lectures going
away at a movie or a play the experience
of the audience being part of an
audience that the
feeling or sensing the other people
around you
is part of the benefit of it oh i think
that's a really interesting question i
think so i think it's you know it's the
community thing you know and i think a
lecture is such a living experience you
know all of a sudden on you know
whatever whenever valentine's day was or
the day before i was in the middle of my
lecture and of course the logs burst in
to serenade someone and i immediately
threw them out because i just need it
all the time you know but that was a
kind of that was a participatory thing
you know everyone was in it and they
applauded my you know throwing out the
logs after i'd done it you know
and we had a really good rapport for the
rest of the lecture you know so i think
there's sort of the incidental
experience you know or the professor
writes something incorrect on the board
that's always a bonding experience for
the class when the professor has to
correct herself
so i think yeah there's this kind of you
know this real time real people who are
you sitting next to you know and so on
that um it makes it a real
an experience you know when you know
you're alive there it's it's actually a
real living experience
i would add that i think the analogy
between theater and lecture is is real
uh you know what might have thought that
live theater would disappear when movies
reached a certain quality and you could
have color and now even
three-dimensional movies
but despite
many many years of excellent movies live
theater is
well and going strong and probably there
are more live theater productions per
year now than than ever in the past
and it doesn't seem to be dying anytime
soon
i think there really is something about
the live experience that excites people
and i think it's almost as true for
academic lectures as it is for theater
performances there's no question i think
that the sort of existential energy that
exists in a live classroom is a
critical element in in teaching but the
question of course is whether or not the
sort of information that's presented in
a lecture really couldn't be presented
just as concisely in
in prose why is it that is it is it a
failure on the student's part that they
can't they just don't have the energy
but they're it's it makes it easier for
them to absorb the information it's a
complicated issue but i had one other
observation about lecturing i'm not sure
there's i don't know enough about
science teaching to to be sure but i
have the sense that what i do when i
lecture in a literature course or in in
the film course uh involves
something more than presenting
information i i mean i try to be as
rigorous and exact and as fact-filled as
i can be in the lecture and i spend a
lot of time organizing how i want to
present it and the information that i
want to give them but i but i i
what i but i never write my lectures out
and and uh this is i'm copying the best
lecture i ever studied with when i was
an undergraduate who i found
really uh inspired me
what i try to do when i lecture and i
think a lot of the people that have
meant the most to me as teachers have
done this i think what i'm also doing
for the students is modeling thinking
that is to say because i don't write it
out even though i know the stuff
backwards and forward and if i didn't
know the material very well i don't
think i would be effective but because i
know the material so well it seems to
the students as if i'm actually sort of
struggling to figure out what i want to
say all i'm actually doing is trying to
sort of we know all the facts i have and
sort of decide what emphasis i want to
put on the conversation at this moment
but the effect of it is to create an i
is to at least create a kind of
drama
in which they can see the professor
struggling to figure something out
or working on articulating something
clearly and i have come to think that
that's the essence of why
my lectures matter to the students not
because the information i give them they
could get from a book
but the but the way i organize the
material the way i put the material
together and especially the way i model
the process
of synthesizing the material is i think
what is special about the lecture i'm
not sure but that's how i have come to
feel about it i'm not sure whether this
makes sense to the rest of you but
or whether it would work in science
because i mean there is sort of basic
information you need to i mean i don't
know whether you need to model
how you think about the theory of
relativity you just tell them what the
theory of relativity is it's not exactly
anyways it seems to me if we're talking
about an interpretive
enterprise like teaching like humanity's
teaching
this may be the kind of model i'm
talking about may be more compelling
but nonetheless
it can't be completely true that there's
a difference because a science lecture
is still engaged in the same act of
synthesizing and organizing
uh that i've described here and it would
seem to me it would have something of
the same consequence but i'm not certain
about it do you wanna talk about well
you know i think i'd go back to my point
that at the introductory level and at
the more advanced level the
strategy of teaching really changes you
know my introductory lectures are
carefully orchestrated i have written
out
everything that i'm going to put on each
of my 12 blackboards and i've written
the time
at which i am going to complete
what is on each
and you know i really try to follow that
um and i try to put kind of fun things
in my lectures you know i teach in
10-minute increments we have a stretch
halfway through i take myself to the
back of the room we have a little quiz
you know there's stuff right we have a
good time for our 50 minutes together
but it's really carefully orchestrated
at the graduate level that's much less
true it's really much more discoursive
and i go in and start talking about
something and i'm armed with lots of
material and literature and so on but
there really are honest questions that i
would like to engage with
the students on and then it really is a
question i don't exactly i don't know
what they're going to give me the
answers for sometimes i do sometimes i
know some of the answers and some of
them they're times they're a complete
surprise which is really fantastic and
then it's much more you know what you
alluded to there's kind of a process by
which the material is synthesized as
it's delivered
i don't think that works at the
introductory level where you know
there's a lot of students and there's
not much time and there's material that
one has to get through so that they can
go on to their problem set which is due
at the end of the week you know
well one thing we've been talking about
without confronting it directly is the
is the
digital revolution is what what they
implicate and all of all of the folks
here in uh uh all about the panelists
here have digital projects of various
kinds
robert has an edx uh uh course in the
art of poetry that is about to be uh
published uh uh
um
second iteration we did it last year
and the second iteration begins march
24th so i've already done it and and
both of you have digital projects that
you might briefly mention that would be
helpful for people to know about uh well
my favorite course to teach is a course
called the early universe which is what
i work on
and that is now available in ocw with
videos and so on it's not a mooc but the
lectures and problem sets are all
available
i have a lot of digital projects in the
works the
one of them is called pre-701 getting up
to speed in biology it's for the
students the 15 of students who really
can't handle introductory biology
because mit introductory biology is kind
of at a high level so i started a new
course over iap which is
bringing people up to speed and that i
taught and developed the material and
it's going to go on to mitx
over the summer and then i have another
project called frontiers of development
which is a synthesis of all of the
wonderful scholars who teach
developmental biology here at mit and
really it's going to be a very modular
course where people will be able to pick
and choose what they want to know about
development whether they're cancer
biologists or
introductory students or ceos of
companies who want to kind of know
what's going on in the field so that's
fun
and then i have a whole project to
develop recitation problems that are
going to be up on
mitx when they're
developed
but hey someone use i'm going to use
this electronic thing to have another
thought that came to me i never thought
of it before about lectures
maybe an advantage of the lecture
compared to the textbook
is that it's an important aspect of
teaching we haven't mentioned was that
it's exigent
it execs things from the students
you can't read at your own pace the
lecture has its own
rhythm
and
you must
exercise your ability to absorb to take
notes to reflect
good lecturers sometimes say this is
very important so don't write it write
it down
don't write this down because it matters
and there's that rhythm of what is uh
merely being absorbed for later
reflection what is to be attended to
right away that demands a lot of the
students i left that out of my
description of uh
my monday talk with these global fellows
i said i'm not scolding you and i said
to them meaning it
we let you down
we the the creative writing program did
not provide you with an exacting
set of requirements for these proposals
even though they're proposals you'll get
the money for with you
whatever we think
we should have begun the conversation by
saying you must have a definition you
must have a
set of people or books that you're going
to do and a strength of the lecture that
i miss in the mooc i'm proud of the mooc
but the mooc doesn't happen it's in real
time for each separate student
separately and in that
audience or that assembly that community
for the lecture
you you know you're you're doing
exercising together you're trying to get
somewhere in that 50 minutes or whatever
hazel here's one question that occurred
to me as you were speaking about your
digital projects
it seems as if the digital projects you
described would
not contain the existential energies you
were praising in the classroom
do you think that's true and that does
that mean that we think that you
actually think digital
education is therefore limited that it
will really never replace uh
ordinary lectures
well you know i think that's an
interesting question i'm i'm not a
actually i really dislike the flipped
classroom notion i think it's just
really bothers me
the flipped classroom yes
it's it's a concept that i really
dislike so i think you know um like you
know my digital projects are ones that
sort of augment the actual in person
projects and rather than replace them or
are something completely different the
developmental biology course i'm putting
together frontiers of development isn't
like nothing that exists at mit it's
kind of a synthesis of bits of
scholarship that i think will come
together in a really novel way and so
that it's different it's just different
there is no lecture course that it is
supplanting and you know it's a it's
therefore in my opinion a worthwhile um
kind of uh process
i
you know
i think there are places where excellent
lectures that are digital
are really helpful for students and
really
give students the opportunity to
see
lecturers of the highest caliber present
their material in the highest way
but i don't think mit is that place i
think at mit we
can present to our students in person
the material and that that is part of
the privilege of being an mit student
and the experience of being an mit
student i think digital material is very
interesting there's all sorts of stuff
that i've been playing with that i think
really can help students learn in ways
that are more fun that are more
effective but i don't see
you know
changing lectures to digital i i
not here not at mit
the final topic that i want our panel to
discuss before we open it up to the
audience i hope you're all thinking
about ways of arguing and concretizing
what we've been saying is the broad
topic is what i call the politics of
teaching and i don't mean
ideologically
the politics in that sense what i mean
is
the
constant argument and and
anxiety that surrounds the question of
whether or not teaching is truly an
activity that is respected and rewarded
in especially in advanced universities
in elite institutions
one of the oddities about our profession
is that it's one of the very few
professions in which the reward
structure is such that as you become
more well-known and more successful
you're asked to do your job less
because right because the stronger the
teacher
the more elite the institution the
lighter the teaching load
uh that seems contradictory in some ways
to me and uh but more generally what i'd
like us to at least briefly to make some
comments on and talk about a bit before
we open it up for general discussion is
the is the kind of argument that some
that that we often hear from the mouths
of parents
which is uh yeah you go you guys are
very well paid and you teach such a tiny
number of tiny number of classes and uh
my student my my my son or daughter
needs a lot of attention and here you
are cramming them into big lecture
courses uh if you taught a little bit
more if you if your workload was closer
to the workload of this of the civilian
population uh you you would you would be
doing uh the country a favor how how do
how does one respond to that kind of to
that kind of complaint i mean i i want
to admit that i mean i feel that there's
some justice in in the complaint there
is there is a sense in which
although
and of course it varies from institution
to institution but there's a sense in
which
uh
very powerful and gifted teachers who
are perhaps not productive as scholars
are certainly not bound for success in
the elite institutions and
that may not be so serious if the people
who were promoted were good teachers but
the adverse is also sometimes the case
that a person who's not a very good
teacher but is brilliant or apparently
very successful uh researcher will be
retained by the and so
one of the things i i want us to at
least meditate on a little bit is this
recurring complaint not only that
amateurs and civilians make about the
academy but that those of us inside the
academy often feel as well i'm just
wondering if you have
feelings about this if you think the
charge is reasonable or unfair if you
think it's a good thing that the more
successful a researcher is the less that
person has to teach that kind of
question
i could comment i have a lot of opinions
you know i think in a great research
universities it's really a major
currency for promotion which is research
prowess and i think for promotion to
tenure
that that is how a great research
university stays great and i think that
is why our major currency for promotion
to tenure is research prowess
i think
however
i think after tenure
one is able to take full advantage of
the freedoms that being in the academy
afford
and that is really an extraordinary
opportunity
i i'm
writing for the faculty newsletter
an article called the job of professor
because you know we have such a complex
job here as professors but if you look
at the job descriptions in the
advertisements for our junior faculty
there is really it's really you know
we're searching for someone you know in
cosmology or in cancer research
who has an interest in teaching at the
undergraduate and graduate level and
that's it you know that is what our job
descriptions are but in fact as one goes
through the ranks you realize that the
job of professor is extremely complex
that there's teaching and mentoring and
governance and all sorts of things that
whatever you can dream of
you have the freedom to do and so i
think there's a balance at the junior
level where promotion really has to be
about research i think there are rewards
for research throughout one's career
which are appropriate because this is a
research university but i think as
people go on in their careers there
really is the freedom to think about
where to put effort and education is one
of those places and of course education
is more than just teaching there's so
much of it there
that being said i think we do not teach
our faculty to be professors we don't
teach people at the faculty level how to
teach i'm seeing daniel there we've had
a discussion about you know maybe doing
something there i'm looking at haines
who has played a major role in ocw in
putting together you know programs that
are about how we teach
i think we don't do a good job in fact
we don't do any job at all in teaching
faculty how to teach and we don't you
know teach faculty to do all those other
things like manage businesses and you
know manage people and all the other
things that you have to do so i i think
that but but i think that the currency
of promotion that we have right now is
okay and what we really you know need to
make sure is that as faculty move up
through the ranks the freedom to go and
focus on education or on other aspects
of the professorship is supported and is
respected
comment ellen uh yeah i guess i'd like
to say that um speaking
for the department of physics which is
where i'm at and don't know that much
about the details of what happens in
other departments
but in the physics department for at
least the last 10 maybe 20 years
teaching really has played a significant
role
in tenure decisions for example or
promotions in general
it's true that you cannot get a tenured
position in the physics department if
they're teaching alone
you need a solid research record
um and i think it's also true that with
a really fantastic research record you'd
probably get tenure even if you're a
lousy teacher
but nonetheless the common case
is a research case which is incredibly
strong but which
still could go either way because
judging research is a very subjective
thing
and in those cases teaching has played i
think a pretty significant role
in the decisions of who has gotten
tenure in physics and who has not and i
think most of our young faculty really
are incredibly good teachers
uh so i think
there's at least a
shift of emphasis in that direction uh
at least within the physics department
which i think i think is very healthy um
i should also add that i think the basic
emphasis on research
is
real i don't think it should be replaced
by an emphasis on teaching i think what
makes mit a great educational
institution is that we have such experts
in all fields that's really what the
students are coming here for
in the first place uh so i think we're
right to emphasize research but to also
give significant
credence to teaching and and i think
maybe that is actually what's being done
robert
i feel like this is an extremely large
and important this socio-political
nature of teaching i wish i knew more
about the subject
but it's a very very powerful subject
apparently and i wish i did have the
statistics but it may be more than half
of the educational courses the student
per course are taught in community
colleges in this country
increasingly adjuncts and graduate
students teach courses
the admission system at most elite
places maybe at mit less than others is
profoundly corrupt in its history it
began in the 20th century with its roots
mainly in anti-semitism
this whole thing of the well-rounded
person and geographical distribution it
was all designed to keep jews out of
princeton and yale and harvard there's
this book called the chosen that
documents that if we want to have
a country in which can we continue to
have the vitality of previous
generations in relation to education
teaching in community colleges
and in the whole spectrum we have to
start paying attention to it in a way
that we're failing to tremendously
and uh
we are living in a kind of
with our
institutional life
we're living a little bit in a kind of
la la land
we are not in contact with the most
important issues to do with our
profession
and the future of our profession
where the bright people will come from
if we leave it simply to social factors
and to the socionomic activity of the
admissions office all due respect to the
admissions office we decay
as a society so the socio-political
questions about teaching are larger and
much more important than i can deal with
i'm embarrassed that i don't know more
about them but i am aware of them
and as a transition to the
mooc
as i said i'm proud of my mooc
i've been struck by how much
educational governance people
provosts and presidents and deans are
extremely interested
in my mooc
more than in most other things i do
and i'm afraid it may have to do
with what you alluded to with this idea
that somehow
we have a wonderful new technological
alternative
to the way we've been doing this and
especially we can give it to the masses
it will solve social problems and
inequities i that's disturbing to me not
just that it can save us a lot of money
we can fire all our money we can have it
and have a we can pay we can
the poetry education for all the
community colleges i i've
the most
i'll talk about two
um
i'll talk about a couple of defects i
found with the mooc
it was very successful the only bu
edx move that had more
resistive attrition veteran had higher
enrollment was the baseball saber
metrics
so unexpectedly poetry and as again i'm
made uneasy by the congratulations i get
for this
and um
it's based on videos that mit helped me
make i recommend them to everyone
favoritepoem.org
favoritepoem.org you'll see a
construction worker
reading whitman talking very cogently
about whitman
you'll see a wonderful um
photography student talk about a silvia
play he's a jamaican guy
and the sylvia plathbone speaks to him
you'll see a cambodian-american high
school student in san jose read a
langston hughes poem
and those are very short they have the
virtue of being three to five minutes
and they are one element in the course
i added
five to 12-minute mini-lectures and then
we had discussion groups and the
discussion groups included a poetry
teacher
the guy who does the garden at my
condo
a high school student again a range of
professions and ages about 10 minutes
each
and when we finish the mooc
the edx people and the bu people were
very interested on the next iteration of
the mooc i found myself much less so i'm
glad to do it but my great concern i
described it to them as the trough
i wanted this to be
a bit like a book or a library
can we not make
a website where there's just a list of
these things
just describe the 10-minute lectures and
describe the they're edited down to 10
or 50 discussions and just have them
where the person with intellectual
curiosity is though in a public library
can just
go through the trough none of the
structure of a course it's not a course
it's a set of resources it's a digital
it's a it's a book in the cloud whatever
you want to call it and
i was i felt that these materials we had
assembled
arranging them in a course
was all too soothing or all too
attractive if you want to substitute
this for courses
and i was more interested in them as
materials
than those courses so i'm happy to do it
as a course it sounds as if you made an
anthology rather than a systematic
course
well we made a systematic course and in
some ways the thing that interested me
most was the anthology of discussions
lectures pros all of that together
incidentally about the technological
science subjects and
discussion subjects
the edx platform we had discussion pods
this may have to do they say it's going
to be better they hadn't done that many
humanities courses
our discussions
collapsed the edx software
it crashed
he couldn't deal with all the many many
people who had a lot of yaking they
wanted to do about poems
they had not run into this and i had my
graduate students slaves were
having dialogue with these people
and edx
couldn't handle it
i
i just i'm really interested to hear i'm
chair of the mitx faculty advisory
committee i'm there as kind of joe
faculty member who knows who does not
program you know but can represent and
with a wonderful committee you know
represent the interests of the faculty
and actually we were just talking today
about the limitations of the mitx edx
platform and reaching out to get
feedback on those limitations and then
trying to address them so you know your
experience is an awesome one to document
somebody told me i had a meeting with
the nx people i was merciless ah good
great they were so nice about it and
somebody explained to me afterwards
programmers
love complaints
they're delighted to hear that thing was
a mess
it's like a game for them right
well i i i let me ask the audience to
sort of concentrate your minds for for
uh comments and questions but i i want
to
i have a sort of transition anecdote
nothing nothing fancy or or or profound
but moving i think
when i was thinking about our session
and talking about the significance or
value of college teaching uh
i i i happened up upon a little squib in
the
times literary supplement of december
4th
and it told us it
it it talked about the great uh
uh literary theorist mikhail bakhtin
about whom uh uh who was a very
honored figure uh as you most of you
know internationally for his for his uh
theoretical and and and uh historical
work but in the city of saransk russia
where he lived as as uh
the tls said in obscurity between 1946
and 1969
i'm quoting here
a former political exile and chain
smoking amputee
but teen is remembered most of all as a
teacher
gesticulating quote gesticulating
passionately mikhail mikhailovich would
sometimes knock his crutches to the
field floor but neither he nor his
audience would notice
mikhail glebochen reminisced in roskaya
gazeta last week
sometimes we would carry him upstairs in
our arms he would lecture without notes
quoting not just poems but vast chunks
of prose word for word
the statue that they
installed marks the 120th anniversary of
bhaktin's death and this image of batten
surrounded by his beloved students
waving his arms being carried up the
stairs oblivious to his own debility
seems to me
resonates with me in ways i can't even
fully articulate
and
something important about teaching is
told in that anecdote
well
questions comments additions attacks
from the audience please
let's let let's hear it from our from
our fellow colleague from our colleagues
from our fellow from our fellow teachers
arthur
if i can just make a little intermission
because
the discussion will be mostly about
lecturing since there are four lectures
in front of us or do other things too
but i was most struck by uh robert
pinsky's
comments
introductory comments
about his a teacher a mechanical
engineer a mechanical drawing teacher
obviously that was straight out of plato
it was a platonic dialogue
and
i guess my question is
uh
have the four of you ever dreamt of
doing something similar yourself
and because it's the absolute antithesis
of the lecture
i i view it that way
so there's
it's it's totally different
but it's a totally different experience
for both the teacher and the student
as
the evidence indicates uh it's what you
came up with
uh
for example have you ever repeated it
yourself tried to do something similar
with a small group of students very
often
i don't have a super i i
hope i have an intuitively organized
mind but i've always been a terrible
note taker
i don't know how to make outlines
i couldn't possibly plan a lecture and
after so many minutes this happens i
need to improvise
i'm made nervous by preparation
and
if i didn't feel i could occasionally go
into the mode
of encouraging students to ask me
considerate questions i couldn't do this
profession i couldn't function in it so
the mac makwithi
example is to some extent
autobiographical i don't want to vaunt
that i am as effective as he was on that
occasion but i rely on it
if all i could i approve of the model of
i think it's much maligned the model of
just pouring information into students a
lot to be said for it
it's really what we're doing is we're
going to die
we're going to try to pour it into them
so they can pour it to somebody else
before they die i don't i'm not
sentimental you know i'm not saying we
mustn't do that
i personally
can only function
by having them
draw something out of me
as on this occasion i couldn't have
prepared anything i've said i rely on
david allen and hazel will say something
you just said something
then i get energized but i i i think for
some of us by which i mean me
that's the only way
uh sir
hi i'm charles licerson uh also mcvicar
fellow which there seemed to be one or
two of us around here from
computer science and uh a little
disappointed not to have some
engineering representation on the uh
panel but that's
that's okay i'll have my say um
uh you know when i looked at the um
announcement for uh this uh the first
line was what separates a good teacher
from a great one
and i think a lot of you from my point
of view you've danced around that
question rather than actually addressing
it uh we heard a lot about wonderful
techniques but we didn't get to
understand uh you know for hazel or for
robert or any of these other things
why these people were using these
techniques
and i think that the answer is
is love
and the answer is the reason you're
doing this is because you love
your audience your students
otherwise why are you doing this
okay
what is it and i think robert the
comment you just made about giving
something of yourself to them that's all
about love
and what i have found is the most
important thing in teaching
is that you actually love your students
because then it dictates all the things
you need to do
in terms of technique
okay because then you prepare for your
students because you love them
okay the difference of the different
formats digital or whatever a lot of
that is it is easier to love somebody
when they are in your arms
okay it is easier to love them when they
are in the room reacting to you i've
written a a very popular textbook in
computer science
and that was a lot harder than lecturing
okay why well because the person that
i'm trying to love isn't there i have to
sort of imagine the person who's there
rather than having them there and i
think until we understand that
that teaching
and learning is all based on emotion
and in particular on
this loving relationship
you know we're going to do this you know
you know what does mcas or no child left
behind have to do with love
nothing that's why those aren't
successful programs until we understand
that kind of thing whether it's k-12 or
graduate the reason that i think that
research is so important
is because you love your research and if
you don't
have somebody you know you get tenure
because you demonstrate you really love
that stuff
and because we're human we really want
to
share our love of things with people we
love
okay and and so i think until people
understand whether it be at an
engineering school or at uh uh you know
humanities or whatever that that's the
foundation of good teaching i don't
think we make much progress in this
country
towards the enormous
uh educational problems that we have to
solve
i have one thing to add i agree with
everything you said but i would add that
it's love also
toward and having received from
your predecessors
the deceased that you remember
personally
but also
i'm the servant of emily dickinson and
of the past
and
one feels a quasi-filial
loyalty
to the dead to the past
and for me it has a lot to do with
mortality then you have a quasi-parental
relationship with the ones younger than
you
i i think i would resist
love as the explanation even though i
think i'm i think i understand your
point but i i i would be much more
comfortable reformulating and partly
because i i've been doing this for 50
years it'd be very promiscuous of me to
have had so many love affairs but
more seriously i i mean i understand
what you're saying but i guess in my own
case
what i think of is i i think i have and
i know other teachers i think allen has
this just from having had conversations
with him uh and i know robert has this
impulse although it's he's become more
imperial as he's become uh
as has become more fake more famous but
but uh
i think that that i have an explainer
gene in me in this i when i know
something i want everybody else to know
it it's not in fact not everybody has
this impulse
and i think that one way to think about
what a teacher is as to distinguish a
teacher from other kinds of authority
figures is to say that one of the really
wonderful things about it maybe this is
a variation on your love principle is
that the authority of the teacher is an
authority the teacher wants to give away
whereas most authority figures want to
hold on to their authority they don't
want to share it but what the the secret
of what a teacher does is he wants to
ideally the secret the teacher wants the
intellectual authority that she has to
be the property of the student this
wants to give it away wants the student
to have it
and uh that may be a more elaborate way
of saying that some i often feel that
i'm burdened with an understanding that
doesn't really become satisfying to me
until other people have it themselves
now and i know this is not universal in
people but i think it's a very common
impulse in reeled in teachers i think
teachers have some desire to let other
people know what they've learned is
their excitement about the value of what
they know
is democratic
now i don't know that's exactly what you
were saying but i think there's a
connection
i could comment you know i think this
question of what's a good teacher and a
great teacher is easily stated but i
think the answer is really complex
because i think there are different
kinds of good teachers and there are
different kinds of great teachers and
you know
i i would be hard-pressed to say these
attributes make a great teacher you know
you've defined how it works for you and
you know that resonates with me some but
i really
look around at my colleagues and i think
there are different ways of presenting
to a group that really you know make me
say wow that's really good it'll make me
say okay fine you know for me it's it's
the connection if i feel like i'm
actually speaking to my 300 students as
individuals then i feel like you know
i've done it and for me the greatest
compliment in the course of valuations
is if a student says you know professor
siv made me feel like i was the only
person in 26 100. then i know i've kind
of got there you know we've made a
connection even amidst this really large
group of students but i do think it's a
complex question and it's got a complex
answer
i'm i'm arthur barr in the literature
faculty um and to the to the point to
the question of good versus great
teachers um one way that i
that that occurred to me to think about
that when i saw the poster for this
event was to think about um teaching as
job versus teaching as vocation
um as something one feels called to do
rather than simply the job that one has
which one may like very much but is a
job that one wouldn't do if it weren't
one's job
and i know speaking for myself
personally that um being a scholar and
being the researcher that um that hazel
like
inhabiting the role that hazel
identified as the correctly as the the
prime mover of promotion decisions at
this institute being a scholar is my job
i'm
good enough at it to have gotten tenure
but it's not my vocation it's not why i
wanted to become a professor
um
and being a teacher is why i wanted to
become a professor
when you first articulated this i
thought it was brave of you and i feel
it now too i i
i think i'm the same but but it's it's
tough to confess
well it it you know there it is the kind
of it is perversely the kind of thing
one can say only after having received
tenure in fact i i mean that i i mean i
mean that quite literally um
and i think but i think more of us need
who feel that way and this is not to say
and
my my point is not that sort of teachers
are noble in precise and inverse
proportion to
the extent to which scholars are smart
right it's um this is
about
getting rid of that kind of value
judgment but i think that will only
happen if more of us who do feel that
way
come out of the closet
yes
use the mic
hi i'm mark hessler i'm an alum from
once upon a time and i've been
experienced quite a bit of the teaching
from people i've heard from here so
that's neat i was a high school english
teacher and science teacher so i'm
tempted to comment on that difference
but i also just want to say about love
i went to ed school once upon a time and
one of the things that i learned there
about teaching
was that unlike other close
relationships it's designed for
termination the goal of the relationship
is that it ends
and that it ends well and so i think
part of doing it well
and the teachers who are very good at it
bear very firmly in mind that that last
day and what they want their students to
walk away with so i think the the
passing of the torch is very important
computer science is much newer so you're
not worried about
people 300 years ago and and their
legacy but indeed in literature
that might be an important part of your
personal sense of mission passing a
torch on because in the end it's the job
of the young to kick the old off the
planet as i said and so we have this
chance as teachers to pass something on
now it's very i think it is very
different with the new and exciting
fields of our digital the madness we're
living through and the new you know the
new opportunities that exist computer
science is right in the middle of that
so it is a little bit different
but ultimately i think the the issue
with love is that
it's a very tough kind of love that
bears in mind that the last day is
coming every day
in computer science and
there's a very long history of passing
down of mathematics and so forth i
wouldn't say and even you know
uh alan turing people are relatively
reasonable goes back to
uh church to goodwill to
you know and you know russell and and uh
whitehead and then take it back into the
greeks
and so forth i mean i i think i have the
same tradition you do and i do think
passing the torch is a is a big piece of
that you know it's uh
it when you put it that way computer
science is built on a map
i had a little bit of experience
teaching math and something that i
didn't expect to feel which i felt doing
it was how incredibly venerable it was
students famously don't like math at the
high school level but i had this feeling
that i was passing on something ancient
and that the curriculum couldn't really
be argued with you know any literature
teacher might choose to teach a book and
the kids can argue oh why do we have to
read that and the teacher has to be very
clever and creative to convince the kids
that it's a good idea to read it but
with math there's really very little
argument they can make you know it's
this is this is how it's been done for
2500 years the pythagorean theorem and
and they they're forced to respect it so
there's an authority behind math
teaching and i suppose computer science
that doesn't exist for humanities
humanity teachers have to create their
own authority and i think david that's
where
the passion comes in i i okay i'm
talking more than i mention but i'll say
one more thing the the
um
about the science versus humanities one
difference at the high school level is
that
kids have a great deal of experience
being people and living so they're kind
of prepared to be
like grad students
and
in terms of the teacher can interact
with them as very mature people and can
trust that the students have a lot of
experience with life and with if it's an
english class that they've read a lot
already even if they don't read much but
in particular they have a lot of
experience being human so in humanities
they're already kind of experts by the
time you have them in high school or as
undergraduates whereas in biology i
imagine if it's you know you're talking
about pre 701 a student who hasn't a
student at 17 or 18 or 20 is not yet
really steeped in biology and is not an
expert so i think that's why
the
teaching a freshman english class could
be like teaching a graduate seminar and
that in terms of that difference that
you're dealing with experts at being
human whereas you're not dealing with
experts in biology at that age so i
think that's a really big difference and
all the strategies change and maybe they
become more like the graduate strategies
i had other things to say but i'll stop
thanking thank you mark
yes
i teach at an institute where my
students are for the most part smarter
than i am
and um
they're just more
flexible in their ability to use what
they know
um
i think i know more and over time one
develops competence and
but
you guys have me thinking hazel's
emphasis on permission to think outside
the box and and
robert's work on moocs and david's grave
acknowledgement about his suspicion of
his own
charm as a lecturer
you guys have me thinking about a moment
in dante i'm i'm really sorry alan um
about halfway through the down the
inferno and it's deep down um
dante puts his teacher brunetto lattini
um he locates him as a uh
maybe a sodomite maybe an invert um
maybe
introverted
right but they
they
dance in a circle facing each other and
and their the reign of fire falls on
them and i've always wondered why does
dante do that
there's no
contemporary evidence that
latini was
so my question is
he's his beloved teacher and mentor
and he greets him
affectionately so my question is either
to the humanists why why does dante do
that if it's
true that's a weird thing to do if it's
not true it's an even weirder thing to
do right um
it's either
why does not do that or
is there something in there about the
teacher student relationship and the
need for the
to leave the student room to surpass the
teacher or
get past the teacher or something
which maybe we should ask the dante
translator today
he even says
he even says if it were up to me
burnetto you would not be suffering like
this
which is um
like a very layered unpleasant joke
because
maybe we should he's writing this but
hold on a second robert maybe
look not everyone in the audience is up
on dante maybe we should be more
explicit about this moment it is a very
dramatic moment in the inferno
stephen said it right but let's repeat
it stephen
dante is meeting his favorite teacher
his mentor and his mentor is deep in the
it's being punished he's deep deep in
hell he's in the lower circles of hell
and steven's saying why is he there i
thought the answer was fairly obvious
that he had violated god's rule uh what
dante believed to be god's uh law by
being homosexual but but uh and and so
that even though dante feels great
affection for him and benefited from
this man god's laws are inflexible and
that's why he has to be here but the
more
so that but that's but but it's been a
crux for those of you who don't know the
passage it's been a crux for years
especially for teachers exactly because
of the drama that stephen is talking
about
now tell us what it means robert i think
stephen was talking to something that i
thought when mark was speaking
i recently read my wife is on the last
chapter last phases of a book she's
writing
about psychoanalysis
and a large part of the book is about
they use the term termination
as they do use the term love and that
also that therapeutic relationship
is also one
it's a very close relationship
whose purpose is
to end
they have that rather peculiar latin
term for it
and i think what stephen is implying and
he wasn't his teacher in any sense
that's very similar to what we do at
yale or amherst or at mit it wasn't a
classroom
he it was much more personal instruction
but dr ellen pinsky
in this very
tech you know professional book she does
use the term love
and she does use also the term vengeance
that the neutrality
of the um
the book is called mortal gifts has to
do with mortality and the fact that the
therapist
can die
eventually will die and is mortal in the
sense of imperfection it's a function
perhaps like teaching as she says could
not be performed by a robot or an angel
or a jonathan swift winnem
it can only if that therapeutic function
can only be performed by someone who is
mortal
and i think what stephen is implying
in the dante passage is that
in a quasi-parental
or quasi-filial relationship
there would be an element of rage
inventions
wow
for the comments yes
she proposes that this one does in
therapy i think one does in life
as mr rogers used to say it's the very
same people
that make you angry
and make you glad
and of course in teaching i i agree with
the that
in a way you love students
and after the class is over you realize
a particular student was really an
annoying person
somebody didn't much like but while the
class is happening
you you know you're you're in that
role you're trying to give them what you
got
to to hand it on
and um i would imagine their psychic
energy comes from could that controlling
or channeling that
as with being a dad or a child
you know if you're a parent or a child
you have to know how to deal with the
fact that you
if you weren't so cute i would probably
eat you
yes sir
so i'm daniel jackson from computer
science this has been an incredibly
inspiring and thought-provoking
discussion
and we've talked mostly about the role
of teachers
and i wonder if we could talk from a
mint about the role of students
and in particular think about learning
it seems to me that one of the most
important things about teaching is
teaching our students how to learn and
indeed i think that's one of the values
of a lecture that it's simply a good
skill to learn to be able to sit and
listen to somebody talk and if we
eliminate lectures from our curriculum
then our students will never require
that skill
i think a lot about my own teaching
failures
and i also think about my students
learning failures and to what extent i'm
responsible for those
but there is one
moment of student failure that i'm most
upset about and i think i am undoubtedly
partially to blame for it but i also
believe that our culture is to blame for
it and i'd like to tell you what it is
um i very avidly note the number of
students who turn up to my lectures as a
as a sort of ongoing measure of whether
i'm doing a good job or not and my
students are normally in the main class
i teach in their third or fourth year
and they're pretty jaded already and
they're very overworked and so it i have
to admit it's a fight to get them to
come to lecture and i sort of relish
that fight
but there is always one thing that i
regard as a terrible failure which is
there is one lecture that i cannot get
them to come to
and that is the lecture in which
their colleagues their peers
present their work and receive awards
for it
and i find this deeply upsetting and i i
do all kinds of games to try and make
this lecture more exciting but i know
why they don't come they don't come
because there'll be nothing they'll be
tested on there'll be nothing they'll be
graded on um it's a lecture it's
actually the last lecture of the class
and i don't have a norm our normal
little quiz games and stuff um which
create tiny little
tiny little uh incentives for them to
come
and i wonder you know i think as a
computer scientist i should think about
programming but i really think more
about deprogramming
and i wonder if we need to de-program
our students that they've developed such
an instrumental notion of education what
it's about
um that they don't uh well they won't
say they don't have the sense of
community that hazel talked about but we
have to fight against the culture we're
in in order to in order to establish
that notion of community and i
personally feel that it's a big struggle
and i don't know if i'm alone in this
but if it's entirely due to my own fault
as a teacher but i wonder if there's
something we need to do as an
institution to instill in our students
the value of being being part of this
community and playing their role as as
learners
i think that's a profoundly important
point about the about how instrumental
the students sometimes are the
atmosphere encourages it there are they
have they're so over scheduled and so
busy that they're often doing triage on
their courses
i
one form that that takes in the
humanities
for is that exams are not always
necessarily the most appropriate way to
measure what students do in the
humanities but the problem is
if you don't give them regular work some
equivalent to exams and problem sets
they don't treat their courses in our
part of the institute with the same
seriousness than rigor that they do the
other side and there are all kinds of
tricks you can play but i mean and i
feel guilty when i have to do it create
a weekly assignment that
keeps them working a kind of equivalent
of that other tricks like that
in small classes what i hope to do
sometimes and it's amazing i try to use
your trick of measuring their their
their interest and as a to judge whether
i've been successful is i actually try
to teach them without exams to get a set
but although i make them perform in
class and write short assignments
and i try to estimate how
engaged they are week by week and it's
when i'm successful i can see they're
doing the work and keeping up but when
i'm not successful it's almost always
because i have not scheduled regular
exams that would make them do it now i
don't know what the solution is but it's
an it's an issue that i've never
resolved fully yes
i teach in the writing program
could you use the microphone even though
it's only a comment because we're
recording this so it won't be heard
otherwise
thank you hi i'm karen i teach in the
writing program and i've i have some
experience using peer review
so i teach courses in the biology
department but as the writing instructor
and i'm very interested in developing
that and i'd be happy to share some
ideas with you because peer review
um although it hasn't been my intention
to to sort of institute it for that
purpose particularly but i think the
effect can be can be helpful for for the
problem that you mention which i guess
we're we're all aware of thank you you
reminded me of the most discouraging
depressing and doleful thing i've ever
known about teaching
years ago i taught at wellesley college
where they had a very elaborate student
evaluation system
and somebody
you all could probably put this better
than i did
somebody took that data
and excluded the good from the bad to
the wonderful today they tried to make
the data reflect
which category of course
won the highest ratings
from the wellesley students
by category you mean watch what was it
what depart department what kind of
course i see okay
why is this so depressing to you
wait booby okay
first year of a language
because
the lectures are closely related to the
textbook and the examinations
your grade is
very precisely proportionate to the
amount of time and energy you put into
it
it's
the
contract for the grade is very clear
and after you've mastered the material
it is not required to think about it at
all
that last is very depressing that's for
sure the whole thing is it's that that
is where the contract is clear so all
the energy you put into being loving is
it
the customers
or employees however you want to think
of them and what you mean by
instrumental is
that's on the model of the larger
society grades are their pay a place
like wellesley they're all tremendous
great inflation and they're all you know
already passed a lot of hurdles but it's
still the mentality they've been trained
that way so they their pay level
the the salary is very precisely related
to work you put into and you don't have
to do all this clumsy awkward thing of
thinking and understanding
and
that is
patently i think the explanation of why
the most popular kind of course is the
first year of a language and i try to
keep that
in the back of my mind not the front
i i can you know that's a good story
you know i think it's really interesting
i think the question of coming to
lecture is kind of part of the college
experience question you know this is one
of your freedoms right you come to
college
i have a lot of thoughts about the
college experience and a lot of them i
really just like aspects of
how our students view college but you
know there's this tremendous freedom to
decide what you're going to do and
lecture is one of the places
there's usually no obvious penalty for
not going to
and so that's especially true in the
large lecture courses now you can use
clicker technology to make sure you're
there and you can get you know five
percent of your grade if you actually
click in i don't choose clickers in my
graduate class you know actually 25 of
their grade is for showing up and you
know if it's a small class if they're
not there it's very glaring and i you
know email them right after and ask
where they were in a large class that's
not true and i think it's kind of
embedded in this notion of freedom you
know i'll get through introductory
biology even if i'm not there you know
and that probably is going to be true
because our students are super smart and
it's probably true in many places so i
think that there's actually you know a
sociological
underpinnings really to addressing why
students go to lecture and don't go to
lecture and it doesn't have everything
to do with the quality of the lecture
at all
i will say a year ago
we had a terrible semester of losing a
couple of students and you know i have
never had greater attendance in my class
that semester because there really was a
sense of the usefulness of the community
and the support of the community um
and that was really quite striking to me
that the you know room was full and we
were you know so sad together
but in a kind of regular semester which
of course you know is far preferable
yeah that's you know there's students
who just don't come and you say you know
you would be much easier if you did come
to lecture but
there they are they've got other stuff
to do and exercising the freedom of
not coming it's i think it's quite
interesting
i might just say that i've also been
disappointed in some of my classes this
past time i was teaching a freshman
class 801l
and i did kind of discover it took me a
while discovered i wasn't as alert as i
should have been but i kind of did
discover by the end of the term if i
talked about anything that was not going
to be on the exam
they really tuned out they really didn't
want to waste any time on that and i do
find that very disappointing
among more upper-class students though i
think things are much better in my upper
class classes
i don't think i've seen that very much
and i've also spent a fair amount of
time probably everybody else has too uh
supervising research projects through
the ur program of our students uh right
now i have three or four uop students or
at least students who are sort of doing
something in parallel with your app if
it's not officially through through
europe and they're great they they
really do very rapidly become totally
dedicated to the project and it's just
delightful to work with students in that
context
yes
hi so uh i'm nicholas i'm actually a
student here um i like coming to these
things because i get to ask older people
kind of what's happened and and
and um
the question i have is uh how how you
how you've seen student expectations
change over over kind of the past 20 30
years um especially people who teach
engineering subjects or computer science
subjects
because i really feel uh
kind of sitting in the dorms and talking
with people that um students at mit and
especially in particular come to college
to to to more be trained to learn kind
of workplace skills to be able to code
in java to be able to solve an
engineering problem or to build rockets
to go to space
and um and so i'm wondering if you've if
you felt any any shift in
in teaching students uh whose whose
perspectives have changed over the
decades
i think you're good
your computers
you have to start i mean
well i'll start
let allen think i'll let alan think
about his answer which will be much more
weighty than mine i don't think that i
don't think in the humanities that i've
seen a tremendous change because people
don't come to mit with their primary
choice to be studying literature or
history or or
anthropology
there has been in my
40 years at mit and 50 years as a as a
full-time professor
a decline in students writing skills
they come into the institution less well
less effective writers than they were
half a century ago when i began
and even in the uh uh i would say in the
last 20 years at mit i think i've
noticed that the the the students are
less effective prose writers than they
were before i i think we at mit have
have not done a good job in emphasizing
the importance of communication skills
and in some ways we've been evasive
about it because we've been reluctant to
do what
seems to me sort of obvious which is to
have some kind of equivalent of a
freshman english course that has to be
got through or
uh or you you could pass out of it if
you passed an exam but otherwise would
have to take it and
that i think might solve some of our
problems but but apart from that i've
seen
no real change in the students except
perhaps that they have
they seem to have less time and they
seem
from my angle at least
much more motivated to sort of uh get to
graduate school and and because they
become more utilitarian maybe than they
had been but that's a marginal change
my own my broadest experience is it's
been unbelievably exhilarating life
enhancing beyond anything i could have
imagined to be around these
these brilliant children for such a long
time i mean i i
i have tremendous admiration for these
students
okay i guess i'd like to start out by
saying that although i've been here for
35 years on the faculty i guess if i do
the subtraction um i have a lot of
trouble discerning trends i think old
trends happen
too adiabatically for me to really
follow them that's my shortcoming i
presume i just have a short memory so
but i guess if i tried to discern any
trends
i think over the years that i've been
here the student body has become more
diverse in many ways
more diverse ethnically racially and
background and more diverse in their
interests which is probably the main
thing that affects teaching
um
back when i first came here a
fantastic fraction of the incoming
students wanted to be physicists which i
thought was great and now it's a vastly
smaller fraction and now they're more
people interested in biology and
computer science and
there really seemed to be a lot of
students interested in solving the
problems of the world in various ways
which i tremendously admire so when i
talk to
the students especially in a large
course like 801 l where they have all
different backgrounds
i'm very impressed by the wide range of
interests
at the same time i think it does mean
that they have a somewhat less
preparation for technical subjects like
801l
um and that that does
show up as well
uh oh no i think it's a good thing i
think we really do have a fantastic
group of students and
besides the freshmen that i deal with i
mentioned i deal with a number of europe
students who really are interested in
going into physics and they are
absolutely fantastic i've met some of
the most fantastic people
in that context uh so i love our
students i think they're great and i
feel very privileged to be teaching here
i i think you know our students are
awesome they're great i think they worry
you know there's so much worry about
where they're going to get jobs and
their parents are worried about where
they're going to get jobs and they're so
worried that if they're going to get a b
in 701 and that's the end of their lives
you know and it's um i think we so
seldom point out to our students that we
have a 97
graduation rate here and actually
they're all going to get their degrees
and that you know actually there's
probably a zero percent unemployment
rate from anyone with an mit degree you
know it's these really positives that i
feel like um
are
really crucial to communicate to our
students and their parents and i can't
remember you know if it was like that
when i came here i think i was so
worried about getting tenure actually i
wasn't really worried about getting
tenure but i was so worried about you
know trying to set up a research group
and do something meaningful i didn't pay
attention so i have no idea if that's
changed over the years at all but i do
think you know there's this kind of
undercurrent of worrying about
employing my own feeling is that that is
it has increased i think that there's an
anxiety level that's greater than it was
that's right and i think you know it is
really up to the faculty to kind of
defuse that because in fact it is not a
valid worry for mit students you know
our students really go on and they all
do well and they all do something useful
and they all earn a living and they all
you know
pretty much do just fine
so i think you know this kind of worry
is something that we could do better at
defusing when we spoke when we speak to
our students you know one one quick
anecdote about that
about
about 10 years into my time at mit i
chatted with some of the students in the
lecture course i teach the film
experience
and
found that they were full of anxiety
that i hadn't uh understood and i didn't
realize was there and i so i uh
toward the end about two-thirds of the
way through the term i gave a brief
mini lecture at the start of the before
i actually went into the substance of
the course and essentially the the
lecture was you know there's life after
failure if you get an f in a course you
survive if you take a term off and come
back you survive uh if you if you
postpone graduation by a year you
survive and i was on i was amazed by the
outpouring of gratitude i got from the
students and i've now institutionalized
that lecture and every year about
two-thirds of the way through the term i
say this in my lecture it's the largest
course i teach something between 50 and
80 students
in a good term
and i think it's a helpful
message for the students to get but
every year one or another student comes
up to me and says it would be much
better if a professor of physics were
saying this
so i'm passing the torch to allen
okay i'll take up the challenge
give me a text though make it easier
i want to thank the audience and thank
our panel
we finished